cuándo
[Música]
los juegos olímpicos de tokio llegan hoy
a su fin después de 17 días de deporte
de alto nivel y en medio de la pandemia
de kobe 19 estados unidos china y japón
fueron los primeros en el medallero y
desde hoy oficialmente empezará la
preparación para parís 2024
lionel messí oficializó su salida del
barcelona el club catalán anunció el
pasado jueves que no podría renovar a
messi por razones económicas y
estructurales y era imposible inscribir
al jugador en la liga al no poder
cumplir con el fair play financiero
según el diario le parisien el paris
saint german podría ser la nueva casa
del jugador
y sigue el avance del grupo talibán en
afganistán este domingo tomaron el
control de dos capitales regionales más
kunduz y sharp bolt con estas ya son
cuatro grandes ciudades de provincia en
manos de los insurgentes desde mayo
cuando comenzó la retirada de las tropas
extranjeras la población sigue en
desplazamiento
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 sierra blanca y
como siempre un gusto acompañarlos
comenzamos con los juegos olímpicos de
tokio que hoy lamentablemente ya llegan
a su fin la ceremonia de clausura se
lleva a cabo en el estadio de la capital
japonesa con un aforo reducido debido a
la emergencia sanitaria por cuenta de la
pandilla en el medallero general
eeuu se queda con el primer lugar por
ser el país ganadora de más medallas de
oro seguido de chiná y el anfitrión
japón habrá también una presentación
referente a parís y la cultura de esa
ciudad por ser la sede de las próximas
justas en el año 2024 en el estudio me
acompaña a uno de nuestros periodistas
deportivos luis méndez
louis muy buen día bienvenido y le
pregunto qué balance entonces podemos
hacer de estos juegos y cómo queda el
medallero pero primero comenzamos por el
balance raúl creo que fue positivo para
japón positivo para tokio para haber
realizado estos juegos unos juegos que
fueron controvertidos desde sus inicios
primero por el tema de la pandemia y
luego por una serie de situaciones
extradeportivas scanda
mayoritariamente que se fueron
presentando a lo largo de la
organización de los mismos pero que poco
a poco tanto los autoridades de tokio de
japón y del comité organizador pudieron
ir solventando para llevar a cabo estos
juegos respecto al medallero tu segunda
pregunta creo que lo importante en este
caso es la recuperación que tuvo eeuu
eeuu
quizás no tuvo los juegos deseados
perdieron o dejaron de ganar muchas
medallas en disciplinas que eran
dominantes como la natación pero en la
última jornada pudieron reponerse y
superar a china en cuanto al medallero
general
así es luís y estos juegos se llevan a
cabo con muchos tropiezos por cuenta de
esta pandemia de kobe 19 le pregunto que
podemos hablar sobre este tema y también
el desempeño de los latinoamericanos
respecto al tema del cob y 19 fue un
mucha la preocupación que se generó al
principio sobre todo a días de inaugurar
los juegos cuando empezaron a llegar las
delegaciones porque se empezaron a
generar contagios en cuanto a los
atletas y también en delegaciones hubo
casos de atletas que no pudieron
presentarse el más sonado fue el del
español jon round en el golf que no pudo
estar
los juegos por contagiarse de kobe 19
días antes de comenzar la competición en
este sentido creo que pudieron también
bajar los niveles de contagio y de esta
manera desarrollar unos juegos seguros
que fue el planteamiento de tokio en
todo momento por otro lado en cuanto al
desempeño de américa latina' creo que
fue extraordinario con países que
lograron su primer oro en estos juegos y
también otros que mejoraron su actuación
respecto al río 2016 ahora a los
próximos juegos se llevarán a cabo en
parís el año 2024 cómo se prepare la
ciudad para este gran evento deportivo
bueno la ciudad ya se viene preparando
en cuanto a lo que son las instalaciones
que van a albergar a cada una de las
disciplinas que estarán formando parte
del programa también hay que desarrollar
que en cuanto a los atletas tendrán un
ciclo olímpico más corto puesto que en
los juegos ahora tendrán un año menos de
preparación entonces va a ser un poco
acelerado para muchos pero también hay
que resaltar que tokio fue la despedida
para algunos entonces va a ser el inicio
de un nuevo proceso
de los atletas también estar a la
expectativa de nuevas disciplinas que
van a estar presentes
así es como siempre muchísimas gracias
so por toda la información deportiva y
también seguimos con deportes porque en
medio de lágrimas
lionel messi se despidió el fc barcelona
el delantero argentino aseguró que hizo
todo lo posible por quedarse en el
equipo y que este es un momento difícil
en su carrera deportiva hablando de su
futuro no confirmó cuál será su próximo
equipo aunque no desmintió su llegada al
paris saint german messi que
recientemente ganó la copa américa con
argentina se va con un gran palmarés del
club catalán ganó 10 ligas españolas
siete copas del rey cuatro champions
league entre otros además marcó 672
goles y jugó 778 encuentros escuchamos
las palabras del jugador argentino
este año estaba convencido mi familia y
yo de que íbamos a seguir acá que vamos
a seguir en nuestra casa que era lo que
más queríamos no sé lo que tengo claro
que yo sí hice todo lo posible
el club laporta dijo que no que no se
pudo por un tema de liga que quería
preguntar precisamente sobre eso está
sonando mucho el nombre del parís saint
germain como destino tuyo dónde vas a ir
dónde vas a jugar la próxima temporada
bueno es una posibilidad sinceramente al
día de hoy esta altura hasta ahora no
tengo nada arreglado con nadie para
ampliar este tema vamos hasta barcelona
con nuestra corresponsal él y sigas en
el ellis muy buena tarde para usted
varios medios franceses dan como hecho
que el psc será el nuevo equipo de
lionel messi y él no lo desmintió
durante esta rueda de prensa que dijo
que dio este domingo que más detalles se
sabe sobre esta lista
pues buenas tardes raúl de momento no
hay ninguna confirmación oficial como lo
acaban de escuchar pero lo que sí que
está claro como lo confirmó messi en
esta rueda de prensa es que están
hablando actualmente con el club
parisino pero también añadió que en
cuanto se hizo oficial su marcha del
club barcelona pues había recibido otras
ofertas de otros clubes lo que está
seguro es que messi sigue con ganas de
jugar y aquí pues centenares de
aficionados se congregaron con el
convencimiento de que messi se llega al
psg porque él según ellos es el único
club que se puede permitir
económicamente al crack argentino de
hecho algunos franceses turistas estaban
también aquí frente a este con ellos
para celebrar la marcha de messi del
club blaugrana pero messi también dejó
claro una cosa que volverá a barcelona
por sí mismo porque se lo cometió a sus
hijos y segundo dijo porque aquí es su
casa ellis cómo queda entonces el hígado
y cuál es y cómo queda la liga española
pues el legado de messi aquí son cifras
impresionantes 21 años de carrera 35
títulos de hecho estos treinta y cinco
trofeos estaban expuestos en el
auditorio donde se celebrada esta rueda
de prensa del camp nou y es una
exhibición que impresiona obviamente
pero también impresiona su legado para
la liga española de fútbol 383 son las
victorias en la competición doméstica
con lo que es actualmente messi pues el
jugador con más triunfos en esta liga y
así podríamos seguir con más cifras que
prueban los récords del crack argentino
obviamente significa que hoy la liga
pues pierde a un gran jugador y esto le
afectará económicamente como también
afectará al club y hoy afectaba a los
aficionados que muchos estaban aquí él
jogando frente al camp nou esperando a
que esa llega el argentino para
despedirse por última vez del crack en
el camp nou y no es para menos ese
sentimiento de tristeza de lis gracias
por su reporte nosotros continuamos con
más información que a quien él
este domingo el grupo talibán tomó el
control de una ciudad clave kunduz en el
norte y también desharé paul en el
noroeste de la población civil de
afganistán huye de estos feroces
combates mientras las fuerzas
gubernamentales afganas luchan por
detener el avance de los talibanes desde
mayo los insurgentes han hecho un
progreso constante primero ganando el
control del campo y ahora capturando
sistemáticamente las capitales de
provincia los ataques en la capital
kabul también se han intensificado desde
la retirada de las tropas
estadounidenses de la nación
obligados a huir de sus hogares las
familias se aglutinan en una escuela en
desuso en la ciudad de astrada avap en
la provincia de kunar en el este del
país son sólo algunas de las miles de
personas desplazadas luego tan duras
atleta de iván poco lo van de granda
pasa los talibanes llegaron y empezaron
a luchar en nuestro pueblo mis animales
desaparecieron hubo disparos una de mis
hijas de siete años salió durante los
combates y desapareció no sé si está
vivo o muerto desde el viernes cuatro
capitales de provincias han caído en
manos de los insurgentes
las últimas conquistas de los talibanes
con surf una gran ciudad norteña sarepul
previamente se tomaron sever hand house
and y zaranj a la capital de la
provincia nin bros un funcionario local
de nin ros culpó a kabul
cuando miembros estaba amenazada por
todas partes pedimos ayuda porque no
había suficiente apoyo militar hace años
que no hay suficiente policía ejército y
patrullas de frontera tu agua va
saladillo ser camps gran parte del campo
ha caído en manos del grupo islamista
desde mayo cuando las tropas extranjeras
se marcharon
washington sostiene que la retirada de
sus fuerzas fue la decisión correcta
después de 20 años de conflicto la
retirada de eeuu se completará justo
antes del aniversario número 20 de los
atentados del 11 de septiembre
el senado de eeuu acordó avanzar hacia
la votación del plan de infraestructura
propuesto por el presidente yo bailé en
un procedimiento que allana el camino de
este importante proyecto la propuesta
pasará directamente a votación final
aunque no quedó claro cuándo se dará la
misma el ex presidente de una forma
calificó este acuerdo como una vergüenza
con 67 votos a favor y 27 en contra joe
biden está a punto de entrar en lo que
él llama el siglo americano su plan de
1.2 billones de dólares de inversiones
en infraestructuras acaba de ser avalado
por los senadores fue el resultado de
complicadas negociaciones y de un raro
consenso entre demócratas y republicanos
se trata de un compromiso
republicanos y demócratas tienen una
visión radicalmente diferente hoy en día
pero estamos de acuerdo en que hay que
crear infraestructuras que funcionen
para todos nuestros ciudadanos
este plan calcula 550 mil millones de
dólares en nuevos gastos federales
cuando 450 mil millones de fondos ya
están atribuidos a otras partidas el
objetivo modernizar los equipos antiguos
como carreteras puentes puertos y
aeropuertos pero también renovar los
circuitos de agua potable y de
electricidad y por fin invertir en el
internet de alta velocidad
joe biden ve las cosas en grande y se
felicita de ver
proyecto de ley en buen camino este
acuerdo representa una inversión
histórica no podemos permitirnos no
hacerlo un paso decisivo acaba de ser
superado
falta someter el texto a la cámara de
representantes donde los demócratas
controlan la mayoría un voto final
favorable podría significar una gloriosa
victoria para el presidente yo bailé y
este domingo el ministro de sanidad
francés oliver ferrán anunció la
disminución de varias exigencias antes
de que mañana entre en vigencia y
certificado sanitario para entrar a
bares restaurantes y otros lugares
públicos la rebajada de estas medidas
contempla que para entrar a un sitio
público será válido una prueba negativa
de menos de 72 horas sino como 48 como
inicialmente estaba contemplado además
de una pcr o prueba de antígenos también
se aceptará un autotest el ministro hizo
públicas estas modificaciones un día
después de las nuevas manifestaciones
contra la exigencia de este certificado
la peor ola de calor en 30 años en
grecia ha generado incendios en gran
parte del país el fuego ha cobrado la
vida de al menos dos personas y miles se
han tenido que evacuar de sus hogares la
segunda isla más grande del país
hevia se enfrenta a gigantescos
incendios desde el día estaba
convirtiéndose en una de las situaciones
más delicadas del país
el fuego parece incontrolable al sexto
día de incendios en grecia las llamas
dejan al menos dos víctimas fatales
miles de personas evacuadas y centenares
de hectáreas arrasadas varios países de
la unión europea enviaron aviones
bomberos para ayudar a los equipos
griegos que se trasladaron a las zonas
afectadas para intentar controlar el
fuego
la cruz roja' helénica está entregando
comida y suministros ámbar impone una de
las zonas a las afueras de atenas en la
capital berna ganador kirchner estamos
aquí para ayudar a las personas que
están en la primera línea al
departamento de bomberos a los
voluntarios a la policía griega y a los
ciudadanos de catástrofe que nokia e7
exterior y más las labores de control de
incendios ya han reducido algunos de los
focos más graves como en los suburbios
del norte de atenas el ide y pfos ya
grupos de habitantes del suburbio
volvieron a sus hogares a pesar de las
advertencias de las autoridades y
encontraron graves daños en sus
viviendas el incendio comenzó por ese
lado y bajó por toda esa zona
actualmente la peor situación la vive la
segunda isla más grande del país en
donde los incendios que comenzaron hace
cinco días aún no han podido ser
apagados entre el sábado en la noche y
el domingo en la mañana 83 personas
fueron sacadas de la isla grecia vive la
peor ola de calor en más de 30 años las
llamas han quemado bosques hogares y
negocios el primer ministro calificó
este verano como una pesadilla
hasta aquí el informativo buen día
[Música]